- So more evidence comes out
that former President Trump
was indeed trying to pressure the DOJ
to overturn the 2020 election.
Specifically, the Biden
administration has released notes
of a December 27th meeting
between former President Trump
and then acting Attorney
General Jeffrey Rosen,
as well as Assistant
Deputy Attorney General
Richard Donoghue.
The notes, and this goes under the heading
of real lawyers take notes,
the notes indicate that Trump was going
through his whole litany
of insane election conspiracy theories.
To which, Rosen and Donoghue pushed back,
saying that they couldn't do the things
that he wanted them to.
To which, former President Trump replied
he didn't expect them to do
it, but he said specifically,
"Just say that the election was corrupt,
and leave the rest to me
and the R congressmen."
And we lawyers call that
a Zelensky maneuver.
Just announced that
there's an investigation
or things are corrupt without
any evidence whatsoever,
and then hope you can make hay out of it.
So maybe that's good for
your own personal purposes,
but it's not good for the rule of law.
So we'll see if this ends up in court.